لقد هبطنا منذ لحظات قليلة هنا
في مطار كابول الدولي ومن
الواضح أن وتيرة الإجلاء
بدأت تنتشر هناك طائرات
تغادر بانتظام الآن وأعداد كبيرة
من اللاجئين الذين تم إجلاؤهم يستعدون
للصعود على تلك الرحلات الجوية ،
هذه مجموعة  يتجهون
إلى قطر حيث يأملون بعد ذلك
إما البقاء هناك أو المضي قدمًا ،
فأنت على وشك ترك
ما يدور في ذهنك
وقلبك وقلبك في الوقت الحالي ، نعم
بالفعل لقد قلت هذا مرات عديدة مع
الآخرين  في الوقت الحالي لدي شعور مختلط ،
كوني صحفيًا ،
ربما أكون محظوظًا بما يكفي لمغادرة البلاد
بسبب الكثير من السمات الموجودة
هنا ،
لكنني أيضًا
أترك عائلة وعائلة بأكملها
ورائي وهذا كثير من الأصدقاء ورائي
أعني أيضًا أن الأهم من
ذلك كله هو أنني نشأت وولدت هنا في مدينتي كابول ،
وهذا حقًا يبدو
أنني أختار قطعة واحدة من روحي لكنني
أترك الكثير من
القطع في المنزل ، لذا فهي حقًا  سترا
لا أعرف كيف أصف هذا ،
أنا سعيد ، أنا حزين مع هذه الحكومة
مع هؤلاء الحكام الجدد
أه
هم متأكدون من أنهم لن يتركوا
لنا أي مساحة لنكون هنا
يجب أن يكسر
قلبك بالطبع بالتأكيد هذا  أن هذا
قد كسر بالفعل ولكنك
تعلم أن هذه هي الحقيقة
التي تحطم قلبك بالفعل ، نعم نعم نعم ،
إنها ليست فقط المآسي الشخصية
التي تحطم القلب هنا ، إنها
مأساة أفغانستان نفسها لمدة 20
عامًا ، لذلك اعتقد الملايين من الناس
أنهم  سيحصلون على
دعم غربي كانوا يؤمنون بتطور
تعليم الإناث لفنون السينما ،
لقد اعتقدوا أن لديهم مستقبلًا الآن حيث أن
المستقبل يطير على متن الطائرة
ويغادر حيث قال لي أحد الأشخاص الذين تم إجلاؤهم للتو
إن أفغانستان تشهد هجرة أدمغة كاملة
سام كايلي  سي إن إن مطار كابول الدولي